so yes we are back with that jjk heat
time to go over the actually like I
can't even believe it 12th Arc in gecko
tomi's Beast of a series that Institute
Kaizen of course if you are new around
here and want to watch more long form
explain content just like this then
remember to hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on your
video as it really does help out with
pushing my content to a bunch of new
amazing people anyways enough of me
rambling on is per usual let's get into
the one and only sakurajima colony from
Jujutsu kaizen's Cullen game so like
remember how right at the end of The
Last jjk Arc we found the monster
herself Marky and the sakurajima colony
well after dispatching the toughest
curse spirits and players she runs into
Naruto shikemo who's undergone like a
clean ass looking transformation man
literally had to switch up his entire
look after realizing he's named after
the worst sorcerer in their family's
history but anyways anyways they both
acknowledge the change in each other's
lock with narutoshi confessing that he's
lost his position as the Kamer family's
ear and is fallen from Grace while Marky
has become formidable Naruto she asks
Maki to meet with you you once she
leaves the colony as you know like
remember because of a recent
transformation he can freely travel
between colonies but suddenly their
planes are interrupted by the sudden
appearance of a formidable cursed Spirit
as it enters shooting in through the
barrier it disregards kogane's request
to becoming new player telling her to
shut up anyway skipping away from like
the action as per usual and going into a
moment that happened a few days prior we
find a hurry narutoshikaimo running
through the house searching for people
until he comes face to face or they see
now she know by the way look has anyone
noticed the dramatic change in Gage
akatami's art style from like the
beginning of the series till now I feel
like the Cullen game especially has
changed into this like darker Arc where
his art especially is a lot more
scratchy and like has this more of a
horror style feel to it but anyways
anyways continuing on they say now old
dog asks how kamo got in claiming that
ever since the guard was taken over it's
been completely useless narutoshi tells
the old fart though that it doesn't have
any time for jokes but Shino eerily asks
him and he's forgotten who's actually
the next head of the family as you then
continue spouting more bizarre nonsense
a warrior she presses on and enters the
house inside he is greeted by the body
swapping creep himself kinjaku who's
literally just chilling out and relaxing
as he was waiting for narutoshi to
arrive kinjaku greets narutoshi with a
smile and offers to filament on his
plans he explains how he used Jujutsu
terrorism the ceiling of Saturday Gojo
and the killing game to eliminate all
the uncorrupted members of the Jujutsu
Society he knew that because Goku ganji
is considered trustworthy and had
influence whether he said higher up
narutoshi would have wanted to plead
with him in an attempt to retract those
notices from the headquarters you know
like talking about the notices that was
handed out earlier like the ceiling of
Saturday Gojo and the killing of Yuji
sidori anyway anyway so he took care of
everyone who wasn't on his side like
Gojo Goku ganji masamichi and others
like that we probably never even met to
start with by the way the actual text
that goes over this is like much more
confusing where they explain pretty much
how kinshaku managed to take over like
the conservative faction of the Jitsu
World anyways sitting there kinjaku's
lived in Priest as Naruto she's only a
mere student but can already see the
bigger picture and ask how he needs to
actually let down himself narutoshi asks
kinjaku if he's already removed the
people responsible for initiating
sukurukito's execution to which is
confirmed along with a person who named
Yuta as yuji's executioner chuckling and
narutoshi's efforts to approach
kakuganji and fix everything kinjaku
confidently exclaims that they Cameo
Clan was the conservative seat but now
it's all utterly belongs to him along
with the title of the 25th chemo family
head feeling challenged narutoshi Sparks
up in preparation to battle but kinjaku
quickly waves to dismiss him my man
literally laughs at him as like nah bro
just just chill out for one sec confused
narutoshi asks what the hell he's on but
kanjaku just tells him that it's fine
because even if he is alive nothing is
going to change plus he doesn't want to
mess up the new house he tells him
instead to get lost allowing narutoshi
to eventually make his way to where we
find him at the very beginning of this
Arc beckonsucker regime narutoshi and
Maki are left on high alert as they both
spot a supposed curse Spirit chilling
above them in the sky a looking at it
Marky just has this weird and uncanny
feeling instantly approaching him at
lightning speed the cursed Spirit
Rampages towards Marky tearing up and
utterly obliterating everything in his
path it connects with a bulky monkey
it's in a new crashing back and allowing
the disgusting amalgamation of a
curseberg to Pinner against a cliff not
having seen this happen Naruto she
watches as Maki struggles to break free
she attempts to hit her but the curse
for its speed as too much food to handle
as it Dodges out of the way of the
attack and sends a shooting into a
nearby Cliff face completely deforming
nerds despite being at a disadvantage
Maki refuses to give up since he's
something weird about this curse spur
out what determination in her eyes she
quickly Dodges out of the way of the
monster's thundering right Hawk however
the curse manages to flick its snakey
behind around destroying a few trees in
its wake and trapping the sorcerer up
against the cliff emerging from the head
of the curse Spirit no one other than
the misogynistic goon himself
naioyazinen now reincarnated as a
terrifyingly strong cursed Spirit
reveals himself pinned up against the
wall and unable to move Maki has just
left stunned asked asking if it's
actually him or the older cousin replied
that he's finally arrived at the other
side of course like if any of you are
confused on how this man managed to like
actually come back Mucky thought she
took her brother out with her fists yet
it's like we all know and she isn't
privy to Noah was actually murked by
marky's mother wheeled in a plain steak
Knife so he also wasn't killed by jiu
Jutsu with her and it resulted in him
coming back as a special great curse
Spirit but like I don't even know why I
write these scripts without reading the
next chapter sometimes like literally
right as we jump out of the battle until
we flash back that takes place this time
between Naruto Shi and kakuganji where
they talk about itadori's recent death
sitting there gakukanji asks what to
keep in mind while killing a sorcerer to
which kmo like I just mentioned responds
they must be eliminated using Jujutsu
the story then shoots back over the
sakurajima winnea still has Marquee
penned up against the wall his face
continuing to push even further out of
the cursor's shell quickly Marky comes
to the realization that because she
doesn't have curse energy she failed to
finish nailya off in their previous
fight however now you denies it telling
Maki that she simply doesn't understand
and instead claims that it was her
mother who finished him off while
Marquis live shocked with this news
naoya takes full advantage of this
situation and declares that he's
returned to completely end her luckily
for our Queen though ignorotoshi blasts
off a shot from his curse tool allowing
Maki to escape the grass by the cursed
spirit that in a way she thanks him but
also asks if he only used intuition to
aim as obviously you know he can't sense
her nearby in the woods narutoshi who's
getting ready for another shot is easily
able to deduce nao's location through
the cursor's prisons however he notices
to do see maki's location as a bit more
difficult which is obviously because the
only energy actually coming off her is
the Jujutsu emanating from the sword
that she wields and I'm like pretty sure
that that doesn't actually happen in the
first place that's just hit Canada mine
right there anyway anyway continuing
finally shooting off his three arrows
technique narutoshi is able to expertly
navigate all his arrows around the trees
and other obstacles on their way towards
the curse now yeah spotting the arrows
bursting through the trees behind him
because Spirit Moxy arrows and their
pathetic Spain taking him once upon
surprise though monkey grabs a hold of
him then using the momentum from his
massive size since I'm flying directly
into the path of the arrows which
penetrate deeply into his body as an
aoyo screams in pain Markie immediately
pulls up and slices him in half with a
cursed hole for my distance narutoshi
watches as Maki Falls onto the buildings
below her while wandering to himself as
she actually managed to exercise naioya
to this shock though our high school of
Duo are left helpless only able to watch
is nowhere's Curse Spirit explodes
before collapsing and on itself like
some kind of cursed energy dark hole
seeing this in the sky above her Maki
immediately begins to recognize what's
actually happening as it fully begins to
form into a ball of energy she screams
out to narutoshi telling him to shoot at
it as she knows it's a cursed one that's
currently evolving the Ravine disaster
and just looking like hella clean by the
way as well like I'm loving the new drip
on narutoshi he immediately throws up
and destroys a blood bag then uses his
curse technique piercing blood to stop
nailya from completing his
transformation The Beam of blood pierces
directly through Neo's cursed womb
causing a massive flood of blood to
begin pouring out the other side
thinking that he could have possibly
exercised the cursed womb narutoshi
watches as the burning ball begins
falling to the ground below yet as he
begins to ponder how insanely fast it
could have been if it survived it's
revealed that area did indeed Dodge the
attack and has evolved into a much more
terrifying form Maki screams from to
dodge but before naioya even is time to
react he's hurt with a devastating blow
that's in some rocketing back through
the forest around them turning around
and calling narutoshi utter trash we see
the grotesque and harrowing sight of
neoya's full transformation into a foul
repulsive curse Spirit noticing that he
managed to defend himself in the attack
nayoyo state that narutoshi is indeed a
clan head after all as kamo sits there
recovering from the blow it's explained
that if he hadn't used his blood to
block the previous blow he would have
died getting back to his feet with a
revived look of determination on his
face he activates his flowing red scale
ability to attack the quickly
approaching curse seeing the curse
hitting narutoshi's way Maki rushes over
and manages to jump in front before
diving straight towards the the curse
and cutting them open with a blade
watching this happen in front of him the
Juiced up narutoshi activates his
Crimson binding technique restraining
the curse spirit and allowing Maki to
strike at him once more yet just as a
swing is about to land naoya spun at a
high velocity to deflect his strike
completely catching monkey by surprise
the combined efforts proved to be
utterly ineffective against nayoya who
still retains his ego from his previous
life getting ready to re-engage Mucky
states that Nagoya can still use his
curse technique which explains why he's
being so monstrously fast in
retaliation's prolific projection
sorcery sending out a bunch of frames in
Marquis Direction which frees anything
that he touches watch also in this
regard is literally the ear between the
two as he instantly touches the set of
frames it creates a devastating
explosion that Maki and narutoshi barely
Dodge undeterred by this nayoya takes
off at a speed faster than sound
confusing narutoshi who wonders of his
flame but Maki corrects him stating that
he's actually just speeding up as the
curses inan is off boasting around the
jewel discuss what what they're going to
do now touch Mahi says that if you're
going to approach them at the speed of
sound then they can lie and wait and
deliver a killing blow so you can see
the cursor's Direction Changed towards
him Marky bravely steps forward to face
nail your head on telling your companion
to stay back as narutoshi also activates
his technique around her in an attempt
to add some protection with the curse
Spirit destroying every shot of glass in
the building as it builds up its speed
it's explained to us that this
misogynistic demon of a curse brings ear
and threw the inlets on its back and
compresses it along with the curse
energy to then inject it out its back
for even more speed with its max speed
of freaking Mark III achieved now your
strikes were such a devastating force
that it leaves Maki almost completely
unconscious and badly injured standing
above her now now your mocks Marky
disgusted with himself to ever think
that he could have possibly lost to her
now you just staked there are things
that children can never do that adults
easily overcome after you grow up you
don't even remember the times where you
constantly failed laughing at the
stupidity of this though Marky mockingly
asks him when he was ever actually in
adult twitch nailya easily tells her
that maybe she should ask who did sister
fearing with anger over how his sister
was disrespected Maggie swiftly stands
back up and in perfect coordination with
her Naruto she unleashes two more arrows
into the malevolent entity dancing and
behind narutoshi then employs his own
blood-bending technique slicing into the
curse and Landing a devastating blow
leaving Nao you're stunned with the
amount of blood being expended by the
sorcerer coming to though he makes a
connection that narutoshi could possibly
be circulating the blood outside of his
body and then bringing it back in
continuously that way he won't die of
blood loss knowing that only Mark he can
defeat him though narutoshi tells His
companion that he'll hold off naoya
while she makes a run for it but Mikey
refuses just asking for five minutes
narutoshi argues though that she's
probably suffered internal damage and
just a brief break won't be enough yet
still Maggie denies it and tells him
that she isn't bluffing and really does
just need five minutes to fully heal her
injuries I don't know how she's like
actually healing herself I'm assuming
that she's probably running over to one
of the healers from Jiu-Jitsu High and
Hill there but that's just a thought of
mine either way hearing this he tells
her that he won't make any promises as
honestly it doesn't really matter
whether he lives or dies reigniting the
battle nail your blasts towards the duo
but Naruto she uses another technique to
form a blood fins before diving out of
the way as naoya effortlessly burst
throughout noticing it Mark is vanish
and because of the fact that she's like
toji he can't seem to nail you asked
where she's gone narutoshi in this
moment analyzes the situation and
realizes that although nairu's curse
body is incredibly fast it's not durable
he also observes that naoya has a
binding valve that requires him to curl
up at high speeds to avoid tearing thus
increasing his toughness but due to that
binding vow itself we're not moving at
high speeds he's extremely vulnerable
all of a sudden striking faster than the
speed of sound narutoshi is completely
taken off guard and blown back through a
bunch of defenseless trees by Nelly is
blow immediately following up the
misogynistic demon speeds up and Rams
straight into the vulnerable sorcerer
causing him to start spewing up blood
with narutoshi Falling Towards the
ground below nayo gives Chase and jokes
they're blowing blood into his Inlet was
a dirty move however narutoshi refuses
to give up and claps his hands together
before delivering a powerful blood beam
straight to naoya's head despite his
efforts though naoya remains completely
unfazed and declares that the Battle Is
Over causing narutoshi to fall into a
childhood flashback so you know big man
himself is having you know his life
flesh before his eyes right now he
believes that honestly he's failed he
was never able to create a safe place
for him and his broken family then
coming back to reality he now sees a
malevolent figure that is naioya leaning
over him again narutoshi is hit by the
shell of naio's curse synonyms shooting
back a few feet but this time the
sorcerer quickly regains his 14 thinking
to himself and knowing that no one in
his personal life needs him anymore
narutoshi attempts to retaliate with a
straight punch while proudly stating
that now it's time to completely burn
away his life then one day in the future
his comrades can do the same upon his
Fallen ashes and obviously gay man you
got to chill out you turn him into a bit
of a bit of a poll or something lines
right here just then as naoya is about
to slip forth and in narutoshi's life
two brand new random ass players
screaming Sumo and Katana arrived to
join the fight so that Rainer man
screaming for a katana is actually an
old schooler who goes by the name of
dido Hagane like the Sumo dude he was
summoned into the current time period
but right in the middle of the kagoshima
sakurajima colony he searched far and
wide night and day looking for a beloved
Katana until one day while searching
through in an abandoned child's room he
finds a kamitsuno yaiba first form water
surface slash sword Hidden Away In A Box
on the other hand and also on like the
2nd of November the other random Cullen
game player Mio who was just summoned
walked around and challenged everyone
that he came across for Sumo he
challenged every man and woman and even
a tam dog but no one accepted his
challengers in the end as he walked
around brokenhearted he heard the phrase
nakota and immediately smashed a
Granny's door down to see a game with
sumo taking place on her television
finally happy with finding that good
stuff he asks for the location and was
told that the fight is happening in Rio
Goku Tokyo I actually love how smooth
brain looking this dude is Pete get gay
main character right here but anyway
anyway man's like hmm ryogoku Tokyo the
capital of the East but you know man is
the biggest smooth brain dude about and
wins the wrong direction he actually
went right and eventually strolled into
the sakurijima colony becoming a culling
game player with narutoshi initially
taken off guard by new people showing up
they either takes advantage of his
situation by sending some tentacles his
way hidal girl clearly shows back up and
cuts off the attacking arm seeing the
weapon that Marky wield Dido screams for
her Katana and runs in a direction
beginning to scream and cry for her
sword knowing that the battle is in a
bit of a stalemate right now Mucky
throws her Katana in the direction of
The Old Man and the hope that an
external Pace to this fight would alter
its outcome instantly as the old giza's
fingers touched the held of Marquis
Katana and grab a hold all four players
feel an overwhelming presence of power
emanate from him it was not cursed
energy but an overwhelming presence of
sheer lethality like a brutal master of
death Stan ending before them it said
that this Dido is The Reincarnation of a
nameless unmatched swordsman who fights
only with a swordsmanship and not with
cursed energy so like he probably does
have curse energy but doesn't know what
it is or doesn't use it for that purpose
anyway anyway slicing at the curse
naioya is just barely able to dodge out
of the way of Dido's attack randomly
though the ancient Samurai gets annoyed
at the katana not actually listening to
him and begins yelling at it asking if
it was trying to shame him like Marky
Dido also has no curse energy and cannot
see the curses so because of that he
asks if there's some kind of ayokashi in
front of him confused as Maki assumed
that he could see it she asks if he
can't he explains that if you can see
everything else besides the cursed
Spirit then it isn't technically the
same as saying it once finishing his
sentence he brings the blade down
connecting directly with naoya and
slicing him in half taking him
completely by surprise Blown Away with
what she just witnessed Mikey tries to
understand how she couldn't land any
lethal attacks on aoya but Dido easily
could under the same conditions she
Ponders what it is that she isn't insane
and what Earth there's still some kind
of difference between her and toji in
the end Maki sends us a simple domain
appear behind her turning around she
sees Mio and is challenged with a Sumo
belt Marky decides to enter his simple
domain and notes it only functions when
he wants to do Sumo it's an extremely
simple barrier focused on only one thing
so you know how he was rolling around
previous to this asking people for sue
her matches well it's actually because
join is pretty Sumo belt both the
Challenger and opponent must agree to a
match to complete his domain due to this
Mio asks Marky for a belt or if she's
like everyone else and is going to
refuse to do Sumo to narutoshi is
annoyance though Marky nonchalantly ends
up agreeing to take part in the belt the
massive open grin appearing on his face
Mio finally achieves Bliss and his
domain begins surrounding in both
confuses to why Maki is entering
narutoshi asks what she was thinking but
Maki actually responds that she was in
fact overthinking and just needed to
blow some steam with the domain fully
covering the duo now Maki enters the
ring and as she it and to a pose begins
to wonder what the hell it is she isn't
seen thinking more she sets upon the
true question that everyone has been
thinking since the introduction of toji
what is she since in the approaching
attack Mayo easily manages to Dart
behind Mahi before she can grab him and
as she turns to counter and certainly
Ducks under her left grab then quickly
spring him back up he manages to lock
his arm perfectly around hers then uses
marky's previous momentum to throw her
over to the edge of the Ring winning the
first bout standing above her Victorious
Mio asks Marky if she's got another
round and her as the moment that he laid
eyes on her he knew that she was much
more powerful doing like the ballsiest
Crouch ever in front of our Queen he
asks what's up and to tell him what's
wrong why why can't you focus it's
explained that Maki never relied on
anyone to become stronger despite having
teachers at the Jujutsu High she always
believed in doing everything on her own
and being self-reliant that's why she
just doesn't know what to say to him
here our smooth brain Mio though seems
that she was still thinking about what
did her had said earlier given her
silence all this time cutting off her
Chain of Thought he asks her to stand up
and have another Sumo match as that's
the only way he knows how to explain
things as they continue a number of
countless matches me up against
explaining to her that she has become
entangled in it all and because of that
she's limited her own progression too
much she needs to instead let herself
loose and experience what it's like to
finally be free while fighting her
opponents then everything before her
eyes like the idea of Victory and the
possibility of defeat will become
meaningless or in other words exactly
what the samurai was talking about
Freedom thanks to the wise words of the
ancient Sumo goat Mio and the multitude
of sumo matches Marky finally knows what
to do next and all she has to do is
experience it for herself where the two
begin in another bout of sumo it skips
fourth and soon comes to an end as she
finishes her match with Mio stepping out
now Marky leaves all of the others
shocked as we see our Queen smiling for
the first time and over a decade finally
ready to be free heavy exited the domain
it's explained that the exchanges Mark
ahead with Mio hadn't even taken one
minute kind of like an uh Dragon Ball Z
with a hyperbolic Time Chamber time
moves slower in Mio's domain and the
time it takes for a thousand Sumo belts
is less than one minute fit up with all
of it though Neo your boosts off into
the sky like last time and begins
raising his speed looking over to the
randoms narutoshi notices them
cooperating and asks who they are but to
his surprise they explain that it
doesn't matter who they are others can
think what they want all they care about
is the new to hold a katana and cut what
needs to be cut or they want to get back
in the ring to wrestle with Marcus some
more back in the battle as nario boosts
around Australia city he becomes annoyed
at the fact that he should be
overwhelming her with speed here for
some reason he can't even touch her
sprinting across a roof now Marquis
season area shoot up and boost off in
front of her completely shattering all
of the glass from all of the nearby
buildings as he reaches near top speed
somehow like I don't know how she's got
this much gas now all of a sudden making
it over and in front of Naomi's
trajectory Maki drops down and begins to
feel everything around her and they
passed she couldn't see without glasses
but once she gained this body thanks to
Mai she became content as she was
finally like everyone else but toji he
wouldn't just reach that height he would
have pushed forwards without hesitation
and even being able to deflect naoya's
top speed attacks with ease seeing what
no one else sees for the first time
Marquis states that it's not enough to
be like everyone else there are things
that only the chosen ones like toji and
herself conceive
boom instantly as Naomi tears through
the building directly in front of
Marquee trying to hit her with his top
speed once more Marky quickly pulls
herself into a ball and manages to dodge
Neo's top speed attack in mid-year
without anything to actually move off
it's just freaking insane a lot of the
fights in the series play off like how
you can catch a person off guard in the
sky as they are unable to completely
Dodge because there's nothing to move
off the skies like untangible so this
just goes to show how much of a beast
Marcus is right now she's literally
smoking on that nahu you pack through
but anyway anyway moving on Maki no is
that the air around them may seem empty
but there are my new differences in the
temperature and air density all marking
needs to do is use them to her Advantage
as naoya then attempts to boost it her
once again Maki easily Dodges and
punches the curse down towards the
ground below Maggie's like also got that
Mega Juiced up brain as somehow she just
knew that Mia was directly below her
allowing him to land a direct headbutt
to the side of the cursor's exoskeleton
not done Dido also reveals himself and
slices at the curse almost completely
cutting through the entirety of neoya
and killing him coming in as well though
and seemingly Landing in the finishing
blow Marky kicks the back of Nemo's
curse but I said in his top half
tumbling across the street in front of
her screaming in denial over his
possible defeat naioya tears his hands
through the shell of his cursewom fully
revealing his human shell while saying
that the only one who deserves to stand
with him is himself before activating
his domain expansion with his domain
expansion time cell Moon Palace active
we see a massive malevolent eye at this
Center staring directly at everyone
within its eye instantly now who
activates his ability on both Mio and
Dido causing frames to erupt from their
bodies taking the ancient ones by
surprise however even more to this
surprise it disappears allowing them to
begin their attack again though as soon
as they move both of them drop to the
ground absolutely overpowered by
nayoya's short hit technique for anyone
as confused as these old boys are it's
actually because of the fact that anyone
naio touches has to move like him or
they freeze for one second what makes it
all the more brutal is how his domain
amplifies his innate technique making it
even more precise not only this he can
even manipulate every cell inside of his
opponent's body and when his opponent
moves every cell will become out of
alignment which explains exactly why Mio
and Dido were severely injured by just
taking one step with Mio collapsing to
the ground he states that it's indeed a
good domain however nayoya only made
this domain expansion for Marquee but as
he tries to sense where she died he
can't find her slightly confused because
this is like his space obviously now you
knows that she he likes curse energy
like toji but thought his domain would
be able to locate her suddenly Dido
purposefully moves his right arm in an
attempt to slice naoya only to instantly
have it decapitated by the annoyed
cursed Spirit you see though and typical
bottom G Behavior now you thought it was
pointless however Dido was constructed
of the same material as our girl and was
able to sense her location checking the
katana and Mark his direction from
within his own Shadows Maki suddenly
appears and grabs her blade before
plunging it straight through a
traitorous cousin's back as we all knew
but like obviously this man right here
just he just couldn't accept the fact
Markie and toji have no cursed energy so
they can easily enter and exit barriers
unless the barrier uses a physical
object as its shell or unless there is a
specific condition placed and because
neuya didn't do that within his domain
he cannot trap her inside of it going
into the twins Dream World for a moment
the sisters are able to reconcile
together as they both recognize that
Maki finally broke free from her curse
correspondingly as explained that they
sawed my left behind as the replica of
the curse tool Soul Liberation blade
that's his sword and now Mark is
obviously ignores the hardness of
everything and cuts this Soul directly
but to use the full potential requires
having a pair of eyes that can see the
soul of anonymous objects Marky has
achieved this and in the end as NAIA
screams at her telling her that she is
lost because she can no longer move
inside of his domain it's explained to
us that this domain's guaranteed hit
can't recognize Marquee due to her lack
of curse energy as I've been going over
so much already and because of that an
oblivious now yoya is completely sliced
in two subsequently causing his domain
to explode while the battle seemingly
coming to an end and both Dido and Mio
shock to somehow still be alive it said
that 12 years after the death of toji
xenon a demonic fighter of equal
strength was finally born honestly you
know it's just so nice to see Mark even
a smile on her face in each panel such a
lovely change from the angry monkey even
though she looked gangster and was just
ready to mess up anyone's day and it's
nice to see her with a smile on your
face for the first time as like her
Mission technically has completely come
to an end now she's just here to be like
a goated warrior and then in the coming
battles pretty much anyway anyway gotta
move forward otherwise all the bottom
G's out there can't take it and I hate
it when I build up amazing female
characters which is really cringe to
them for some reason but anyway so with
the aftermath of Maki and Aria's fight
at Sean that she was fully successful in
exercising her as kamo confirmed the one
Maki claims that the win was thanks to
the randoms that had shown up and
hearing this narutoshi asks about their
condition just like kaimo Dido and Mia's
conditions are also severe but what Mark
is most concerned about is how narutoshi
just nonchalantly decided to throw his
life away narutoshi tells you though
that he should know his situation
because he's from one of the big
families like her he feels worthless as
he's failed to become the head this also
how he was named by his mother after the
most evil sorcerer in history he asks if
Mahi asked hers to what she says that
she did but then she murked her but now
after hearing what the cursing area told
her she doesn't know if it was the right
decision and honestly just worst they
talked more skipping away for a moment
we witnessed a glimpse of camo's past we
remembered his family and how his name
actually originated more or less the
reason as to why she named him narutoshi
was that it was the first thing that
came to her mind and she was paved at
the time she didn't know exactly what
was good for him but just wished that he
would abandon the kamo family and safely
return home to her this little dude who
like I initially thought was kamo as
actually kamo's half brother I I just
had no idea and I thought this was a
flashback with kamo to start with my
brain my brain but anyway anyway he asks
if Naruto she's a nice guy twitch's
Mumsy says that of course he is after
all he's my son so that that brings us
to the very end of what is the
sakurajima colony Arc right here with
Maki and her story pretty much and
everything from Jesus cousin obviously
things are going to pick up drastically
throughout the next two arcs if you know
and have caught up because oh my God 212
and 213 are absolutely insane and I
can't wait to see what happens after so
get high for that and leave it like
we'll try and post those videos like 5K
likes and also leave a comment down
below with what your thoughts are on now
who is like re-emergent I know some
people were hyped and others for some
reason hated this dope Arc it's just a
really really interesting how like the
community was 50 50 on it if you are new
around here then make sure you hit that
subscribe button if you want to keep up
to date with Banger content just like
this and check out my patreon for Early
Access to newer videos by the way I love
you all and I'll see you on a bit bye